then guys we are back here in Austin
South by Southwest and we have to say a
huge thank you to our sponsor
specifically right now Blue Moon Thank
You Blue Moon for letting us be here
because it means we could tell you about
movies like Wild Rose I'm so happy
you're here I already told you I loved
your movie it really just caught me by
surprise because I didn't know all that
much going into it so I kind of want to
go back to the beginning here and I want
to know when you to reconnect it because
you've worked together before right yes
how you reconnected to kind of unite to
make this movie it was essentially you
know sometimes in movies everything goes
against you and sometimes the stars
align and this was one of the cases when
the stars aligned and I were Nicole
Taylor the writer I had been working on
script for a long time for our I came
aboard for about 10 years I think and I
heard various things about it because
our paths had crossed it various
different times but they Ward the
producer was a friend of mine and she
asked me to read the script and I'd
actually come back from Austin where
I've been working and so listening to
country on the radio seeing a lot of
live music it sort of sunk in to me
somehow and at the time the film was
called country music that's like huh
that's fate and and I read it and within
two pages I knew that this character
rose in Harlan could only really be one
person because I mean not only is this
singing a challenge in the performance a
challenge but this character in
particular it's I feel I feel like it's
so easy for her to tip the scale to
being too unlikable at the beginning and
then not being able to appreciate that
growth but I don't know personally I
think you had the perfect balance with
that yeah I'm always absolutely
terrified every single job that I go in
that you know you're not gonna find all
the different colors of this character
make them become as real and human and
relatable as possible and but I suppose
you know Nicole had just written such a
brilliant script and I just wanted to
eek out all those things that usually
people are afraid to let
they'd be seen you know those foibles
especially in female characters and and
her rawness and her like and she's such
of the people you know in Glasgow as a
city of the people that yeah I was I was
thrilled and also terrified but they're
kind of good sources to kind of I
suppose launch yourself off the edge of
the cliff and hope that it goes okay and
you have to you have to kind of show the
less appealing side as well because
that's that's the journey that's the
best thing yeah and that's what might
have that's fun for me I found one of
the most interesting things about the
school the script because it's hard and
we like to portray the best images of
ourselves all the time but the truth is
that we do make wrong decisions and we
are and we do fail and we and we make
mistakes and that's that's what makes us
human and to not acknowledge that is to
deny our humanity you know and and it
makes it all the more rewarding I hope
when when when she reconciles the two
things going on in her life you know on
the one hand trying to bring up and take
responsibility for her family and the
other hand living out her her dreams of
being seen as a singer as a as a as an
artist as a someone who has hopes and
aspirations you can't have that growth
at the end if you don't have all those
flaws before it actually speaking of
that I love hearing about you know
people making mistakes and experiencing
failures and overcoming them because
making a movie at any stage of your
career is not easy so do you guys have
any examples throughout your careers
where you know someone knocked you down
and you kind of had to overcome it yeah
you know and but that's also like if
anything they're kind of like little
golden nuggets because well I don't know
I hurt at the time but it's also I've
got a little bit of a rebellion in me
that kind of goes oh well I'm gonna take
that and something that maybe you think
that I'm not capable of I I get hungry
by wanting
to surprise myself and surprise people
that think I can't do something but uh
and it's amazing the way the rejection
or things that don't go the way you
would like them to can sometimes lead to
other things that you would never been
able to do had that not win the case I
never really see them as like they're
like as well they're just like what they
like Rose Lynn says what's men free
doesn't pass you by and like life is its
own plan for you and you have to you
have to be you have to be prepared to
make mistakes in life and take big risks
and yeah and if you take risks then
sometimes they're not going to come off
but that's definitely but you have to
take the risk
I feel like that's also true even when
you narrow it down to making movies in
particular were there any instances of
something having gone wrong on set that
wound up sparking I don't know something
magical and unexpected ya know like more
than kind of well because we'd worked
before you know we had a kind of
grounding of trust and like I felt like
Tom was pushing me constantly to places
which I was kind of scared to go and
there was a few times when I got quite
bad panic attacks and set and like it
was kind of but they were kind of
extraordinary moments of actually I
really learned something and there is
one scene in particular where I just we
were about to shoot you know times
ticking and and you have to just go and
you're tired and you know and I got a
panic attack and Tom we went aside for a
min and he was like you know that's
really human it's a really human thing
what happens if that belongs to the to
the character and actually I went with
it and actually when we shot it it was
it was in a really interesting moment
for me as an actress because I realized
actually whose those things are you have
to they're part of their at that point
as well you've bled in between the
character in you and it was just part I
just had to you it was it presented
itself and I had to like go with her
it's such an interesting thing that that
that's a very delicate thing that you
can only
I think get get to a place where you can
be in that position between actor and
director
after you really know each other and
really trust each other and know how far
you can push each other yeah because
it's quite a dangerous place to - yeah
if I you know and you can't be glib with
that you can't take that lightly it's a
you know it's a it's a delicate
dangerous exciting place to be and this
is some challenging material for your
young co-stars here - who I want to know
about working with them because they
were phenomenal in this where I mean
that relationship is so hot and cold I
can't imagine the challenge of directing
two really young actors to make sure you
know you're in the right moment in the
right frame of mind at the right time so
how was it working with the two of them
he's not just me I'd say it's reliant on
Jesse on the cameraman on the whole set
to be ready to capture what they had to
give particularly with with Lyle and and
so you know Jesse was great with him
because it's just about knowing when to
slip into character knowing when to slip
out when he needed you know and actually
we we tried all sorts of different
approaches and different times were more
appropriate rather than you know
sometimes he needed to hear action in
order to stop messing around and other
times it was just about Jason having a
conversation
yeah and capturing it without him being
conscious the camera was rolling I loved
those kids though and they're so
brilliant in it and the girl who plays
Daisy
you know her Winona Daisy's her name
it's such a yeah there they were
brilliant really no real presence having
excited oh such a great energy into the
scenes there and they really do I wanted
to ask you guys your opinion on what do
you think it is about country music that
really speaks to a lot of people I know
there's probably a variety of answers
but maybe to you personally well what
spoke to me when I first kind of found
it was
well the lyrics really you know it's for
me it's all about the lyrics and it's
about these very human day-to-day
moments in life that are captured in a
three-minute movie or a song which can
have a way of saying something
incredibly simple with the kind of was
also like managing to kind of plot
inside your heart and you know like a
man man I don't I can't really describe
but it feels like it's just like these
very human honest just normal moments
which are shaved down to the kind of
wrost of what is in these characters in
these songs and and it's about love and
it's about loss and it's about struggle
and it's both in there like just normal
day-to-day kind of things and yeah I
love it it's hard to there but I agree I
just think that you know people find it
hard to be honest and to communicate and
often times and sometimes what music and
particularly country music can do is is
it's free give it space or an ability
people who might otherwise struggle to
communicate to be very direct very
that's that's what I'd love about
country is the directness is very so
honest like as a performer as well like
it's really changed a lot of how I
approach like things you know because
you just have to completely remove
yourself and let it wash through you and
and that's when it's at its best you
know if you try and play something on
top of it you lose the special thing
which is constantly it sort yeah moving
and changing yeah honesty and there's
like a warm quality yeah to it that I I
can't really put into words but there's
something about it that I feel like it's
often a celebration of home yeah feeling
that kind of reflects everything that
happens in the movie too
I have so many more questions for you
guys but I have to wrap it up thank you
guys so much for being here today and
again a congratulations on the movie
please keep an eye out for Wild Rose
also while you're at it why don't you
like and share this interview this is a
great time thank you guys again we will
see you soon with more South by
Southwest coverage
you